a twelve-year-old alabaugh Alabama boy
rather is among the latest victims of
the deadly flu epidemic Aaron Masterson
died on Sunday from flu complications
the CDC recently reported 17 pediatric
flu deaths in one week alone DeMarco
Morgan is at Lehigh Valley Hospital
that's in Allentown Pennsylvania which
has a record number of flu patients
DeMarco good morning good morning to you
the flu season is so bad it could last
until May here at Lehigh Valley Hospital
they are admitting nearly more than 10
percent adults than usual and they are
at capacity and quickly running out of
space this is the mobile cert hospital
Pennsylvania's Lehigh Valley Hospital
setup the surge patient and to deal with
an influx of flu patients dr. David
burmeister is an emergency medicine
doctor here
this flu season seems to be quite a bit
worse than what we've seen in the past
emergency rooms across the country are
overwhelmed the number of people
hospitalized with flu like symptoms is
the highest in almost a decade the CDC
reports nearly 15,000 patients have been
admitted for the flu so far this season
the patient populations that we get most
concerned about are certainly pediatric
patient population at least 53 children
have died from the flu since October 12
year-old Aaron Masterson died Sunday
from complications with the flu the
Alabama boy was born with cystic
fibrosis a rare genetic disorder that
amplify the effects of the virus well
worthy had been friends with Aaron for
seven years it was definitely hard
I cried yeah I'm praying Tom wills mom
Brandi says she considered Aaron a
second son Aaron was a giver an
entertainer and he just loved everybody
hey I'm just mommy we're only one of the
families the many families that were
impacted and touched by Aaron's life
there are hundreds more stories out
there
now Aaron's family is donating his
organs to help others doctors say the
best way to protect yourself is to get
the vaccine and the staff here at Lehigh
Valley they were kind enough to help me
get my very first flu shot just to be on
the safe side
John Wilson thinks back to you tim
marcoh everything there himself with his
own where he go DeMarco thanks